[Music]
it is getting really popular to send
small satellites into space
for
internet provision across the world
particularly where you can't use cables
and so on to remote communities
now the problems with these satellites
are they they need to maneuver in space
to avoid flying objects or because
they're not in quite the right orbit the
problem is they're really small so you
can't have a big rocket engine and you
don't have anywhere for the fuel until
recently there haven't been very many
of these satellites so people have used
xenon gas
the xenon gas is allowed to leak into a
high voltage chamber
where it forms a plasma
and the atoms or ions of xenon are
rejected at huge speed out of the back
of the satellite you may think how's a
little bit of gas going to push the
satellite and the answer is that in
space where there's no air resistance
and things are floating you don't need
very much push to get good movement for
example if you send a milligram of gas
out of the back at a thousand meters a
second that will push a kilogram of
satellite
in the other direction at one millimeter
a second the problem is
that xenon gas has to be held in a gas
cylinder and a high pressure because
it's a gas
and you need to have some sort of
mechanical valve that can open and shut
and
when you're in space
these things might stick
might not open or might stick open
and a recent paper has described how you
can use iodine
which the atoms of iodine are only
slightly lighter than xenon
but iodine is a solid
which if you heat it goes directly into
the gas phase so-called sublimation
and you don't need very much power to
convert the solid to the gas
so this very clever new engine uses
solid iodine which is heated up using
only about one watt of power and
satellites have
solar cells so electrical power
is
essentially free
and then the molecules of iodine i2 are
subjected to a high voltage which
dissociates them generates i plus ions
which can be accelerated
to very high speed and then when they're
ejected you mix them with electrons so
that you get both electrons and ions
going out to the back
because if you didn't your satellite
would become more and more negatively
charged which in the long run wouldn't
be a good idea but there are no moving
parts you have solid iodine
you can store it just as a lamp you
don't need to have a cylinder and in
this paper not only have people devised
this iodine motor
but they've sent it up with the
satellite and demonstrates that it works
they can fire it wait a bit fire it
again and so on
i never dreamt
that iodine could be used to power a
rocket and now a completely new
application
for this element has been found so
next time you're in the desert and log
into the internet
think of the iodine that makes it
possible
change of color that goes so fast you
don't see it changing you can see the
aluminium and the iodine mixed
within this solid mixture seeing the
excess iodine subliming and forming a
vapor now if we go in close we can hear
it fizzing